hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar hands-on
tutorial
workflow advances for whole cell
correlative cryo micro microscopy
i'm susie valdez of labyrinth and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
elaborate and brought to you by leica
microsystems and aviol to learn more
about our sponsors please
visit them at the sponsor logos on the
left side of your screen
so let's get started i'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as
many questions as you want at any time
you want during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
also please notice you can share this
webinar on your personal social media
just click on the social sharing tab and
let your friends and colleagues know
about today's live event
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
simply click on that support tab found
at the top right of your presentation
window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen
i now present today's speaker dr liz
wright and also joining dr wright
for our live question and answer session
will be
dr j yang dr brian seibert
and joseph kim for a complete biography
on our speakers please visit the
biography tab
at the top of your screen dr wright you
may now
begin your presentation welcome
good afternoon thank you for joining us
for today's webinar
a hands-on tutorial about workflows for
correlative light
and electron microscopy for cell biology
we would like to thank our sponsors and
co-organizers leica microsystems
and alveo labs we would also like to
thank lab roots for hosting the webinar
series
as mentioned my name is elizabeth wright
i am a professor at the university of
wisconsin-madison
our research group focuses on questions
related to infectious disease
and human cell dysfunction we develop
and use
a range of cryocorrelative imaging
methods in our research
i would like to introduce three other
presenters for this webinar
and webinar series dr jay
yang is the cryoem biophysicist in the
group
and develops light microscopy cryo-em
and cryo-clem methods and software tools
dr brian seibert is a structural
virologist
on the team he develops and uses light
microscopy
cryo-em and cryo-clem workflows for
virology research
mr joseph kim is a phd student in
physical chemistry
at uw-madison he develops and uses
white microscopy cryo-em and cryo-clem
workflows
for neuroscience research
if you missed our first webinar or would
like a refresher on its content in the
future
you may access the material at lab
routes the webinar
correlative cryo-imaging for cell
biology was presented on june 11
2020 in that webinar we introduced
cryo-em at uw-madison
highlighted major emphasis areas in
structural biology
and connections to cryo-em and clem
we discussed some of the theoretical and
practical aspects
of labeling biological targets and
included research examples
we also discussed clem equipment options
and workflows
including research examples i presented
some future areas for clem technology
development
and a few suggestions about resources
to get us started here is a brief
overview of today's webinar
i will introduce cryo-em at uw-madison
and mention some key reasons for why
cryo
and why clem from there i will discuss
cryo-clem equipment options workflows
and laboratory layout requirements
at this point i will move us into a
practical discussion of micro patterning
with the alveolimo system and cryo clem
with the leica em cryo clem
i will present some future areas for
clem technology development
i will then provide a few suggestions
about resources
make a few acknowledgements and point to
our future webinar events
the right lab moved to uw-madison in
2018 to begin our next phase of work
in cryo-em structural studies of host
pathogen systems
simultaneously we set out to build
acrylium research center
at uw-madison in the department of
biochemistry
to support the research endeavors of
investigators across the uw campus
regionally nationally and
internationally
we have assembled a team of the pi to
staff scientists eric and matt
four post-doctoral research associates
jay
brian julene and daniel
and two graduate students joe and juan
members of the group are engaged in
facility management and technology
development
research projects in the area of
infectious disease and neuroscience
and cryo-em education we are always on
the lookout for new team members
in addition to our team we have a suite
of instrumentation to support
all major cryo-em workflows from the
basics of sample optimization by
negative stain tem
single particle data collection and 3d
map determination
we specialize in areas associated with
cryo-clean
and cryo-electron tomography and have
built resources to support
studies of biological targets from light
level imaging
through cryofib sim sample milling and
priority data collection
3d reconstruction rendering and
sub-volume averaging
the members of the team and
instrumentation are essential for the
success
of cryo-em studies in the wright lab and
the cryo-in research center at
uw-madison
why are researchers actively developing
strategies that use fluorescent light
microscopy
clem and cryo-em briefly
cryo-em technologies were pioneered to
retain specimen hydration
and reduce electron beam radiation
damage to the biological sample
while imaged in the vacuum of the
electron microscope
these advances allow data to be
collected that could be computationally
processed to generate native 3d
structures
of macromolecules from nanometers to
atomic resolution levels
in kind fluorescence light microscopy
was developed for resolving targets of
interest
during the imaging of a living or fixed
specimen
finally correlative light and electron
microscopy
or clem technologies and methods grew
from the need to define the 3d
structures
of macromolecular complexes by em that
has been spatially resolved in
biological samples
by life microscopy in cryoklem
the goal is to achieve direct
correlation data
from the specimen
as we consider the cryo-em workflow to
use so much depends
on the biological question
what is the target an isolated
macromolecule
or macromolecular complex
whole cells perturbed cells
or tissue simultaneous to the
consideration
of biological targets
selection of the technologies used for
sample preservation and imaging
will also impact the relationship
between context
and achievable resolution
when we move forward with a research
project we consider the workflow in four
phases
sample optimization and preparation
specimen preservation
imaging pathway
and computation and data analysis
for this series of webinars we will
focus on the central pipeline for
imaging impact cells
for light microscopy cryofluorescence
flight microscopy and cryo-electron
tomography
we are all investigating exciting
biological questions
that may benefit from light and electron
microscopy imaging
however we may not know what resources
we need for addressing these questions
and whether we should house them in our
own laboratories or use them as part of
a shared resource
there are many options available for
equipment and decisions regarding the
systems to purchase and use
depend on many experimental factors that
are generally determined
during the initial development of a
project and refined over the course of
the investigation
for the ideal and highly automated
cryoklem workflows
one will need access to live cell
imaging systems
a plunge freezer cryo clean microscope
a cryo fit stem for sample thinning
and a cryotem
while we build out a repertoire of
equipment to support light microscopy
cryo-em and cryo-clem studies in our own
labs
and in shared research facilities a
critical component
for overall success is the laboratory
design
and layout at uw-madison
we spent considerable time designing and
building dedicated cryo-em research
laboratories
here in this architectural drawing we
illustrate the layout
of our 900 square foot biosafety level 2
certified tissue culture clem imaging
and cryoe and preparative laboratory
the entire laboratory is rated for bsl1
and bsl-2 work
this includes the appropriate safeguards
for room access
airflow and circulation environmental
safety controls
and ppe and training for personnel
the laboratory has a dedicated hvac
system to maintain
constant temperature and low relative
humidity levels
necessary for minimizing frost and ice
contamination
to cryospecimens during cycles of
specimen preparation
transfer and imaging
we incorporated two tissue or cell
culture rooms
in the overall footprint to maintain a
close proximity
between the wet lab work a live cell
imaging system
the cryo preparative equipment and the
cryo-clem
system this layout supports our efforts
to minimize handling and transport risks
to samples that may be delicate or when
the timing between steps is critical
overall our varied research objectives
have been successful
in part due to the lab design
how do we practically do cryo-clem
we have developed a cryoclem workflow
that includes standard operating
procedures in areas that may require
optimization to improve success rates
of cryoklem experiments for the novice
and experienced practitioner
this workflow is conveniently
color-coded to help the investigator
work through each step
and the associated steps of the process
two areas within the workflow are called
out with red and blue boxes for two
reasons
first when working with cell cultures
both eukaryotic
and prokaryotic it is critical to
maintain
a sterile working environment using the
appropriate environmental controls
and the use of aseptic or sterile
techniques to eliminate possible sources
of sample contamination
second once samples have been plunged
frozen
it is essential to maintain samples
tools
and equipment at temperatures lower than
minus 150 degrees celsius
to minimize specimen defensification or
contamination
in order to help individuals plan and
troubleshoot wholesale cryo-climb
experiments
i will outline a few of the critical
steps within the workflow
when we transition to grid preparation
there are a number of considerations
briefly one should have a standard set
of tools
and laboratory equipment to minimize
specimen contamination
and maintain continuity of research
we prefer to use math tech dishes for
clem imaging experiments
because they have a glass coverslip in
the bottom that allows for periodic
light microscopy imaging without the
introduction of grid handling steps
we commonly add an additional thin layer
of carbon
to the grid surface to improve substrate
stability
and increase cell happiness depending on
the attributes of the biological target
we may use perforated or continuous
carbon film
we may also add an extracellular matrix
protein
across the grid to enhance cell adhesion
and spreading
at this step we may define regions of
the grid
where the extracellular matrix material
is applied
to encourage ordered cell adhesion and
spreading
finally we add both fluorescent and
electron dense markers to the sample
to support correlation and image
alignment
during the reconstruction process
an area of development in our lab and in
other labs
is micro patterning to support complex
cell culturing experiments
and improved automation through glum
pipeline
the leading rationale for micro
patterning is that cells
either eukaryotic or prokaryotic do not
grow in two dimensions
or in isolation therefore technologies
can be developed to support the
expansion
of the native instant true
microenvironments
on a substrate this will increase our
capacity to understand
fundamental cell biology
and design experiments to tease out
architectural
mechanical physiological
and other structural and functional
relationships present
between tissues and organ systems
to support our light microscopy micro
patterning
and clem imaging experiments we designed
a dedicated
flight microscopy imaging lab within the
temperature and humidity controlled
biosafety level 2 laboratory footprint
a workbench for sample prep and handling
a leica dmi8 with the alveolar primo
system
and a leica em cryo clem unit are in the
suite
each microscope is on an air table to
dampen vibrations
the systems are housed in close
proximity to incubators in the tissue
culture labs
as well as the plunge freezing
instruments thus making transitions
between
the culturing imaging and sample
verification steps
seamless
the light microscope is a leica dmi8
onto which the alveol primo micro
patterning system
is mounted the entire system is very
compact
and also supports longer time course
live cell imaging experiments
with the addition of an incubating
chamber
this is a user-friendly system for
imaging and micro patterning the pc runs
three main software packages
micromanager for basic and custom
imaging experiments
the leica las x for correlation
experiment
and the alveolar leonardo for micro
patterning
in this schematic from lpo labs we
review the basic steps in the maskless
photo patterning
process first the substrate such as an
em grid
or a light microscope coverslip is
coated with an anti-fouling agent
i.e peg and then the photoactivatable
plp the liquid or gel agent
second the user will prepare a pattern
with a basic
image creation software the pattern can
be
simply a regular pattern of ordered
lines to complex patterns that include
multiple geometries
and possibly gradients within the
pattern
the pattern is then transferred to the
leonardo software that will control
the substrate patterning process on the
microscope
third the substrate is loaded onto the
microscope platform
registered and then with uv illumination
the pattern is introduced onto the
coated substrate the illumination
process
causes local degradation of the peg
polymer
this material and the excess plpp agent
is rinsed away in the fourth step
the user applies an extracellular matrix
material
antibodies or other biological agent
this material will remain only where the
patterning process
occurred finally one is able to seed
cells at an appropriate density
onto the pattern substrate
at this point we recommend visiting the
alveolab
website to watch a complete video
tutorial
on tem grid micro patterning
in addition there are links to several
papers from the cryo-em community on the
use of micro patterning
in cell biology also
please reach out to the alveo lab team
and the growing user community
we are happy to share our experiences
we hope you take the time to visit the
alveol lab website for more information
and brian and joe's experience the most
critical steps to consider
for the cells are the design of the
pattern and the selection of the ecm
material
it is important to keep the cell type in
mind in particular
what is known about their native
environment
for the patterning process use a stencil
to maintain grid support and hydration
on the coverslip or mat tag dish
in addition during the incubation
periods keep the grids hydrated
in a light protective container
finally how long does the process take
in our hands we are able to move from
pattern design
to cell seating on eight grids in a
matter of five hours
which is very comparable to normal work
with regular grids
in this experiment brian and jay
patterned a substrate to support the
adhesion and spreading
of bas2b cells on an em grid
bastb cells are a human lung epithelial
cell line
that is commonly used for functional and
structural studies
of respiratory pathogens
the two images on the left are from the
atcc
and show how bastd cells spread
across the substrate when they have been
seated either
at low or high density
in our experiment brian and jay's use
the line pattern
for several reasons first
bas2b cells tend to spread and extend
in a linear fashion we aim to replicate
this order present
under standard cell culturing conditions
note the semi-linear order of the
individual cells
in the atcc images
second to orient the cells and have them
spread
over the central region of an em grid
square
the line pattern supports an even and
regular distribution of the cells
across the entire em grid without cell
clumping
or disruption of the underlying em grid
structure
furthermore with extended regions of the
cell periphery
we would have greater opportunity for
locating and imaging
regions of virus entry and attachment
or virus assembly throughout the process
the bas-2b cells were monitored by live
cell imaging
and subsequently cryopreserved for our
cryo-clean
and cryoem imaging
and then panel c and d you can see
the micropatterned
line and then in d you can resolve the
cells
present in those micro pattern lines
in panels e and f we have fluorescence
microscopy images that illustrate the
positioning
of those cells in those particular
regions of the grid
in this experiment brian and jay pattern
several
substrates to support the adhesion and
growth of hela cells
fela cells are a commonly used model
cell line
for studies of cell structure and
function and host pathogen interactions
the two images on the left are from the
atcc and show how hela cells spread
across the substrate
when they have been seated at either low
or high density
in this experiment the triangular
pattern
was used was generated for several
reasons
first to replicate the basal level order
that hela cells tend to have
under standard cell culturing conditions
note their semi-triangular order of the
individual cells
and second to orient the spreading cells
to the central regions of an em grid
square
as can be seen this pattern supports the
even and regular distribution of cells
across the entire em grid
as you can see in panel b
and in panel c and d we can see the
pattern
and then the cells spreading across the
pattern
without cell clumping or disruption to
the underlying em grid structure
once again the hela cells were monitored
by live cell imaging
and subsequently cryopreserved for
cryoclin and cryoemitting
and panel g you can see several of the
cells
have thick eyes present over the top of
them but they are organized in the
triangular pattern
once you have cultured your cells on the
substrate and define the time points at
which the biological process should be
preserved
it's time to veterivize or plunge freeze
the grid
there are many options available for
sample preservation
routinely we plunge freeze wholesale
specimens with the leica emgp
the leica emgp is an automated plunge
moving unit
that has an environmental chamber that
can be calibrated to maintain specific
temperature
and humidity levels to remove excess
liquid from the grid
the system has a single water that can
be programmed to block a sample
from the front or back side once
or multiple times sequentially the
binoculars allow users to visualize the
calibration process
so that sample application and blotting
are reproducible
the computer control panel allows the
user to enter experimental details
including temperature and humidity
values ethane newer temperature
and blotter conditions a double dewar
system is present for condensing
ethane in a safe controlled manner
forceps or tweezers are used for holding
the em grid
and the refillable water chamber serves
to regulate humidity
in the environmental chamber
outlined below on this page are the
major steps in operating
the leica emgp the link
will also bring you to a youtube video
about the leica emgp
in total the entire process for setting
up the unit
and freezing a small batch of grids
takes approximately 30 minutes
so now that you have prepared your
sample imaged it by light microscopy
and vitrified it by plunge freezing or
high pressure freezing
it is time for cryofluorescence imaging
there are many options available for use
the selection of the system depends on
the attributes of the particular system
as well as the biological targets we
decided upon a system that is part of a
seamless workflow
has minimal minimal transfer steps
between systems
and methods for handling that eliminate
possible sample damage
as well as an imaging and coordinate
data
housekeeping system that allows for
rapid correlation
for our work we have had great success
with the leica em cryo clem system for
studies of bacteria
human cells and virus infected cells
the lyca cryoclam has 11 major
components
the liquid nitrogen pump for cooling the
cryo stage
the temperature control unit that
regulates pump function and monitor
system temperatures
the dm6 microscope
a 50x thermally isolated cryo objective
the cryoclin stage that supports loading
and imaging of two samples
the overall microscope control unit
the stage control unit the cryo transfer
shuttle used for loading grids into the
chuck
and onto the cryo clean stage a
fluorescent light source
a cmos or other type of camera
and the pc with the las x and other
software components
as with all steps in cryo em workflows
the most sensitive steps are those that
include sample handling by us
i.e by human hands this is the reason
many systems for cryo-sample processing
to cryo-imaging have automated sequences
multi-specimen options and robotic
elements
leica has engineered a cryotransfer
shuttle that helps to minimize
the number of touches
first note that the cartridge
holds two grids under liquid nitrogen
temperature
in this video you will see three options
for loading em grids into the cartridge
for easier viewing the processes were
demonstrated at room temperature
the first is loading a pre-clipped grid
with specialized support tweezers
pre-clipping gold or other fragile grids
into an auto grid
can be a good idea because the grids are
extremely fragile
and easily damaged the second option
is to load the pre-clipped grids with
standard tweezers
the final method is to load bare grids
using regular tweezers and a grid
alignment tool that is removed
prior to transferring the grid cartridge
to the cryoclone
as you're seeing we have a robust
workflow for cryoclone studies
of virus-infected cells this workflow
relies on tools from
alveol the primo system and leica
namely the emgp and the em cryo-climb
with these tools in hand we are
developing improved routines for better
automation and correlation between the
cryofluorescence microscope
and the cryo-em data here jay
demonstrates the steps
of an improved workflow for correlation
between the cryofluorescence microscope
from like
from the lycos cryo clem and the cryo-em
data
from a 300 kv side entry microscope
the data is of an rsv infected cell
where virus replication competent cells
are indicated in red and the native
immuno-labeled virus particles
fluoresce green
so once you have prepared your specimens
loaded them into the cryo cleanse
transfer shuttle you are ready to begin
clem imaging as you see here joe is
ready at the microscope
notice that he is an appropriate ppe and
he's wearing a face mask
not only because we are in coven 19
times but because any humidity from
our breath that lands on the em grid
can cause devitrification or ice
contamination
in the next two slides we will review
the steps associated with imaging a
single
primo micro patterned trioem grid on the
leica cryo clean
the entire process per grid depending on
grid quality
target number of regions of interest and
number of fluorescence channels needed
may take up to one and a half hours
we performed this experiment with a
single primo
micro-patterned cryo-em grid the
cryo-clem imaging took one and a half
hours
on this grid eas2b cells were cultured
and subsequently infected with rsv
the video captures screenshots of the 21
steps
of the grid mapping and imaging crosses
in the las
x matrix screening the first 10 steps
take approximately 20 minutes and set up
the basic imaging conditions for the
grid
in step one the grid template and the
grid are aligned
and the user selects the imaging
parameters such as the filter cube sets
camera exposure times and single or
multiple channels per position
in steps two through four the user sets
up the imaging parameters
for focus and selects the focus position
in steps five and six the user runs the
focus map
at the pre-selected focus positions
across the entire grid
now in steps seven through ten the user
often reruns
with some manual input the focus
routines
at select a position to fine-tune the
parameters
the next six steps will set up the
mosaic acquisition
and generally takes about 10 minutes to
complete
in step 11 the user defines the mosaic
areas for the data to be acquired
in steps 12 through 15 the imaging
conditions for the mosaics are refined
and they include adjustments to the
filter sets exposure time
and z stack height in step 16
the export parameters are validated and
adjusted
if needed during steps 17
through 19 the grid mosaic is acquired
this process may take up to 40 minutes
depending on the number of channels used
height of the v-stack sampling steps
used
and areas collected the final two steps
to the cryoclaim imaging
process are to identify and mark
registration points over the entire grid
i.e yellow markers in step 20
and then identify targets of interest
for cryo-em data collection
squares with green points and objects of
interest are blue points
this is step 21 and now at last you are
finished
you may continue to the second grid
or finish the process save and export
your data
and recover your grid for transfer to
the cryo-em
so you have made it you have loaded your
sample into
the cryo teu you have your maps and
navigator files
now what briefly with
five screen captures from serial em on a
titan krios
we will walk you through the major
correlation steps on the previous primo
micro patterns grid
the first step is to import the cryo
clean mosaic
the image
then you will import the navigator
registration points
noted in yellow from there you will
transfer the cryoklem image
and the navigator points this is
followed by the transform process
that will allow the image and the
navigator points to transfer
to the tem map pink and red markers
now that you have a large scale map and
the points are registered
you can begin to work on finer
correlation processes
at the level of the grid square pole
and object of interest in this cryo tem
image
we can see the orientation of the bas-2b
cell
along the same trajectory as the primo
micro patterned
area so it's in this orientation
these blobs here are just thicker eyes
that can occur across the en grid
in this webinar we have presented
details about the practical hands-on
aspects
of cell culture em substrate micro
patterning
and cryo clem in our next webinar to be
held in august
we will present a robust correlation
software solution
with a user-friendly graphical user
interface that seamlessly integrates
with any
lm and em instrument
this teaser data is as of an rsv
infected cell where the native
immuno-labeled virus particles fluoresce
green
in the cryo-et reconstruction we resolve
the structure of the virus particle that
was identified
on the cryofluorescence microscope map
of note the label used was fluoro nano
gold
and we are able to resolve the nano gold
particles associated with the f
or fusion glycoprotein on the surface of
the virus particles
now as with all areas in structural
biology we are looking
at the future of cryo-clem imaging
are there improvements to the methods
and technology that will lead to better
and faster results
yes we can consider a range of
improvements
in particular we are interested in
improving substrates and cell culturing
methods through micropatterning
and microfluidics as we demonstrated
today
with the alveo primomo system we are
also engaged in developing improved
automation routines
through software and hardware advances
which we will discuss
discuss in our next webinar series
as you have seen throughout the webinar
we have a robust workflow for cryo-clean
studies
of cells and virus-infected cells this
workflow relies on tools from alveolar
labs
and leica microsystems mainly the dmi8
microscope with the alveolar primo
system
the emgp and the em trioclin
with these tools in hand we are
developing improved routines for cell
culturing
along with better automation and
correlation between cryofluorescence
microscopy
and cryo-em data
everyone always asks what is next how do
i begin
my project where do i start
here i have included a list of resources
within the community
and from leica and alveo labs
there are numerous ways to connect with
cryo-em and light microscopy experts
we are always happy to help answer your
questions
i'd like to acknowledge a few members of
our team
historically cryo clean developments in
the group were led by
sherry hampton josh strauss
rebecca dillard john
and hong yi our latest advances at uw
madison
have been pioneered by the efforts of
jay yang brian cyber
and joseph kim we have also had
wonderful support from our colleagues at
leica
louise bertrand and nancy rizzo
and at alveo labs from aurelian dubois
and serge kadura
i'd like to highlight our upcoming
webinars in the series
and these are webinars that focus on
some of our scientific results
as mentioned in august we will have a
webinar that discusses some improvements
for the automation
routines for correlative microscopy
and then later on we will have two
webinars to discuss how we can use
collaborative imaging
to investigate host pathogen
interactions as well as how we can
advance these routines to study complex
cell to cell
interactions
we really appreciate your attention
today
and we now pause for questions
thank you dr wright for that informative
presentation
and welcome dr skybert and dr
yang and dr johnson welcome all of you
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so
now just click on ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer
as many of those questions as we have
time for
so let's get started our first question
coming in is for you liz what difference
does it make
to use promo primo to prepare myself
samples for cryo ep
thanks this is an excellent question so
in
using the primo system to prepare sale
cell samples for cryo et we can really
work well to ensure that the sample is
well positioned
in the center of the grid squares so
this facilitates a data collection in
the cryofluorescence microscope
and under cryofib milling or cryo-et
conditions
and so this can also help control cell
density
so that we don't have too many cells
growing on the grid we can really
position them well
because if we see too many cells on an
em grid we can
have very thick ice once the samples
vitrified which makes it challenging to
acquire
cryo et data unless we are incorporating
thin milling
into the routine is primal micro
patterning technique compatible with all
em grids and is it causing some damages
to those grids
all right yes thank you i'll try this
again
so we have found it to be compatible
with all carbon em grids
and we've used a variety of those grids
in our lab other groups have also had
success with silicone substrate grids
and i would direct people to the primo
and alveola website to really see the
versatility
of what primo can be used for
as far as damage we do not see
any damage to the grids throughout the
process and we routinely
check the grids by light microscopy at
several points in the process
including during and after patterning
after the extracellular matrix edition
and after self-seeding immediately prior
to freezing
and we don't observe any damage at those
points
nor when we put it in the crow em
microscope
thank you brian and this next question
is for you joe how can i be sure my
micro patterns are aligned with the
frame of the em
grid mesh
so the leonardo software allows you to
visualize the position of the projected
pattern that's overlaid with the bright
field image of your grid and
adjust the position of the pattern if
necessary whether it's by
rotation or translation if
one thinks that the orientation of the
pattern within the square
is not as a high priority there is an
automated positioning workflow that is
included in the software
thank you so much joe and again i want
to thank our audience these are great
questions that are coming
in this next question is actually for
you again joe
which shells can be micro patterned on
em grid
thank you this is an excellent question
um at present
we believe there is a great variety of
cells that can be
micro patterned under the em grid the
success
of such specific cell type would depend
on
optimizing the pattern along with
finding the appropriate extracellular
matrix type
as well as the concentration as a matter
of fact we have recently begun
to micro pattern em grids for trickier
cell types such as
astrocyte-like cell lines as well as
primary neurons
thank you and this next question is for
you jay is the
cryo clem use the main user interface of
las x or is it using the clem workflow
that is
beast left x and matrix screener
um good question so all of the data's
presented
here is actually in the matrix screen
module
but if you have the main screen
that functions on your software which is
the embedded lax
workflow you can also collect your grid
montage there it can also be these
stacks
but uh you probably cannot make the
coordinate point for the registration as
well as
image position that would require other
softwares to do the
uh coordinates transfer
thank you so much and we're gonna come
back to you brian without using micro
patterning
would the cell grow randomly on the grid
is
is micro patterning absolutely necessary
hi that's a great question without
micropatterning the cells
do grow randomly on the grid except
they have a preference to actually grow
above the metal
grid support bars where they can't be
imaged
without patterning if you're very
careful with seating
your cell density you do get some grid
squares
that have a nice distribution of cells
and that are well positioned for imaging
but micro patterning definitely enhances
the number of cells that are well
positioned for cryo eem
imaging compared to seating the cells
randomly on the grid
thank you for that and jay using the
cryo clean workflow you mentioned
there's a possibility to export the
coordinate
as nav to a cryo em
is this work for any type of cryo em
if we are using serial em to control the
electron
microscope uh
good question uh yeah because uh the
lax the software supports multiple
various of the formats when you export
those coordinates
so one of those formats are stereo
navigator files and those navigator
files can be
um imported into serial yams and then
correlated with zero yen for later on
yeah so it's suitable for all types of
the cryo-cleaning combination of
steroids that control the
microscope
thank you for that and liz back to you
do you find that micro patterning
technique
to really save time and cost in the end
it as it adds more steps to the overall
workflow
yeah this is a a great question for
anyone who's thinking about
doing wholesale cryo em and cryo clem
so in many cases the time and cost
savings really depends
on your project goal and the cells that
you're working with
and all those different attributes
in many cases primo can increase the
number of potential imaging targets per
grid
over unpatterned cell seating so this
makes it you have a more seamless
workflow from your cryofluorescence
microscope
to your cryofib and then finally into
your cryo-em
however as with all things there could
be extra time and cost investments
due to micro patterning but in the end
we feel that the balance of having more
usable
cells and information to gather at the
final end of the workflow
outweighs those
components
thank you for that and we're going to
swing back over here to you brian
for sectioning please specify the cell
density
yeah that's a good question and
unfortunately it's one that
really depends on the cell type
that you're seating on the grid we
generally use something like
10 to the fourth cells per mil
on the grid but that again it changes
based on the cell type
so that's something that you really need
to determine for your specific
cells on the grid
thank you so much for that and i just
want to thank our audience we have so
many great questions coming in we're
going to try to answer as many as
possible before
we close today any questions not
answered will be answered via email
by our presenters so let's take a look
joe here's a question for you sorry it
might be a silly question says the
audience member but coming from a single
particle an ep world is globe
discharging
adopted when working with cells on grid
hi this is actually an excellent
question and what i would say
is that because the grids will be
making contact with solution regardless
of whether it's in single particle
or cell cryo et world it is recommended
that you do indeed glow discharge your
grids
before it starts making contact with um
solutions of say the cell aliquot for
what you want to see
your grids onto so it's recommended that
you glue discharge your grid
right before the seating process starts
or before you begin micro patterning
thank you so much and jay i thought the
sample still gets very quickly degraded
from the electron
beam in cryo-em is that true
uh yeah it is true um just like all of
the crowds impose biological samples you
still need to image your samples in
low-dose mode under
the electron microscope
thank you very much and back to you liz
our audience member
first says great presentation how do you
envision
microfluidic technologies playing a role
in cell preparation for cryo-electrons
for photography of the cell
yeah so this is a great question uh
so in our current setups where we're
growing culturing cells on
on a variety of different substrates
including em grids uh that are
made of carbon and copper or gold in the
case of
growing cells and grids or silicon based
materials
most people are just growing these in
culture media and
allowing them to just propagate as
they would but in thinking more
expansively
if we are patterning the grids and
encouraging
them to the cells to grow in particular
arrangements
we can then think about how we can
incorporate
microfluidics into their routine so that
then we could gently
transition the media that the cells are
culturing in we'd have to
develop novel platforms to put the cells
on and microfluidic chambers
so that then we could do time course
experiments
of transitioning culture media to some
other agent
to see how this changes cell
ultrastructure
in response to the changing
physiological environment
is it possible to use fib milling
for determining larger complexes in the
cell
membrane what is the resolution limit in
this case
i think for determining the larger
complex in the cell membrane it
really depends on the labeling when
we're using
cryo clean there is a resolution limit
especially when you are using the wide
field imaging
and generally it achieves between 400 to
800 nanometers and depends on the fluid
force you're using and also some image
processing
afterwards that you are doing to restore
your psf
the point spread functions uh so that
actually determines a lot whether or not
you can find it
when you are doing the fin milling so
i think it's a very practical question
really depends on
what you're looking at and your labeling
and
your sample
thank you so much jay i really
appreciate
you responding to that and i want to
thank all of you
for presenting today and for you liz
for your presentation would you like to
provide any closing remarks
before we close today
sure again we'd like to thank
leica microsystems alveo labs and of
course lab roots for hosting
this webinar series just remember this
is our
second uh webinar and the five part
series and so we'll host another one in
august
where we'll be discussing how to
do a bit more advanced correlation
between cryofluorescence microscopy and
cryo-electron tomography
i'd also like to thank my other speakers
today
jay yang brian fibert and joe kim
and thank you everybody also
representing
and i'd also like to thank you all again
for for all of your work
here's dr liz wright dr brian seibert dr
jay yang joseph kim thank you all for
your
presentation today and for your
contributions
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsors
leicester micro assistants and aviola
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
and before we go i want to thank the
audience for joining us today for their
interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by our seekers via the
contact information
we provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
and we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event until
next time
take care be safe have a great day bye